من السياحه الى خدمه العملاء وحتى الصناعه
وخدمات الاموال ومحطات تلفزيون تنفق الصين
مئات الملايين من الدولارات سنويا على
الموظفين الافتراضيين مع تطور الصناعه في
البلاد اصبح انتاج شخصيه ثلاثيه الابعاد
اقل كلفه بنسبه 80% عام 2021 اليوم يكلفوا
تصميم شخص افتراضي نحو 14000 و300 دولار
الفضائل الالكترونيه الصيني الذي اكتسب
المؤثر في شعبيه كبيره خلال السنوات
الاخيره هو بعيد عن الفضائح الشخصيه لا
يتعرف ضريبيا ولا يسير الجدل هذا ما يؤيده
استطلاعه راي حديث توصل الى ان 45% من
المعلنين قد يتوجهون لرعايه مؤثرا
افتراضيه او يدعونا شخصيه افتراضيه لتمثيل
علامتها التجاريه خلال العام الجاري صناعه
شخصيات او البشر الافتراضيه مزدهره وتتضخم
في الصين خبرنا الغريب هو ان من اشهر
الوظائف في المجال الصحفيون والمذيعون
[موسيقى]
ومن الجانب الاقتصادي تنضم الينا الصحفيه
والاعلاميه الاقتصاديه سمر الماشتا سمر
صباح الخير اهلا بك
بشكل مبسط وبطريقه مبسطه كيف يتم صناعه
وبرمجه الاشخاص الاتيه طيب بدايه سهام
ونادين هي عباره هناك عده مثل او عده طرق
لصناعه هذه الدوله الاشخاص اولا يا اما
تكون هالكرام اللي هي الان كاسات ضوئيه مع
الليزر مع شاشات بحيث يطلع مجسد كامل
وكانت هناك استضافات في دبي اوبراليه عبد
الحليم لام كلثوم ايضا هناك مثلا اللي هي
طبعا اللي هي تكون على شاشه خلفيه
اختراضيه همم هي عباره عن تودي طبعا هذول
الاشخاص يتم همم يعني اذا ما كان في
بهاينده مثلا مذيعات تتكلم يعني هيكون في
شخص همم في خلف الكواليس هو يحكي ويتكلم
وهي مجرد صوره انعكاس عنا على شاشه معينه
بس في اللي هي بنت القاء نفسها مثل
الروبوتات هي عباره عن مش ان نتعلم الاله
مثل اللي نتصل فيهم على البنك وتجننا
دائما اللي طلعت
عصبنا دائما هي عباره عن مشيل لانك تتعلم
انه اذا يسالك كذا جوابك كذا ده يسالك كذا
جوابك كذا بروجرامنج وترد عليك ففي اللي
يكون خلفه شخص حقيقي وفي اللي يكون خلفه
مجرد ماشي او تقنيه تعلم الاله ببساطه
طبعا همم
طب ما انت اصلا عندك كثافه سكانيه كثيره
مليار ونصف المليار- نسمه طب ليه بدهم
يستعينوا بموظفين افتراضين في هالحاله
يمكن هناك وظائف معينه
هتحتاج مثل ما قلنا البنك او مثلا السياحه
كانوا مرشد سياحي او مثلا يعني في وظائف
معينه طلب انك تتكلمين نفس الكلام وتشرحين
نفس الشرح وترديه نفس الردود فبالتالي بعض
هذه الوظائف تتطلب هذا النوع من الاشخاص
او هؤلاء الاشخاص الافتراضيين بس اللي
يصير بالصين اليوم ايضا انه هناك يعني
الغريب في الموضوع انه هناك حركه كامله
يبنون بلديه كامله ليه صناعه هؤلاء
الاشخاص الافتراضيين اللي من المفترض ان
توصل لحجمها لهذه الصناعه سبعه مليار
دولار بعد اربع بعد سنتين في الصين يعني
هناك توجه كامل واستثمارات كامله في عده
شركات تقنيه لبناء هؤلاء الاشخاص ويمكن
مبدئيا هم يعملون في الصين بس اكيد هم
يمون تصديرهم الى العالم وبدينا عندنا من
المساعده الافتراضيه في ايضا التوضي اللي
تظهر على الشاشات بالمطارات اللي عندك
مطارات اليوم بس هو اكيد
الى باقه
انت من استخدامهم والتركيز عليهم في
المقرات الحكوميه في البنوك في المطارات
اليوم هناك شركات خاصه تتوجه لرعايه
العملاء الافتراضيين هل سيكونون يعني
باسعار غاليه او انه تصنيعهم في السيسي
يجعلهم اقل ثمنه خلال سنه واحده بس
التقنيه تطورت بشكل كبير بحث صارت 80
بفي 20 22
نزلت همم هذه التقنيه اليوم يتراوح شخص
الافتراضي الواحد بين 2400$ الى 14 و300
دولار لشخص الافتراضي في السنه كلها وطبعا
هذه مثل مثلا تقنيه البي بي سي الطاقه
الشمسيه بلاش غاليه كل ما تتطور التقنيه
ترخص وبعدين هناك همم توجه مهندس
نعيما
المؤثرين نقينا عليهم قبل الحلقتين جبنه
العديد
45% من المعلمين في الصين شركه في الصين
اعلنت انها توظف شخص التراضي او انفلونسر
مؤثر افتراضي خلال هذا العام وتستغني عن
المؤثرين حقيقيين اولا لانهم يعني ياخذون
كثير
قاعده مشاكل في جني هذه الاموال صارت هناك
صاروا 45% من المعدنين يعني انه بدو
استعدادهم انهم سواء الظفرون مؤثر فيرتوال
اضطرابي بهذا الشركات بتوفر بهذه الحاله
انه مثلا بدل متوظف الموارد بشريه وبشر
هيك بتوفر انه لما بتعمل موظف افتراضي حسب
اذا اذا تريديه 3 دي متكامل 1400 حسب
الوظيفه يعني في وظائف اكيد ما راح توفر
فيها مثل ما قلنا بدل ما توظف يمكن خدمه
العملاء خصوصا هذا الرد على الهاتف بدل ما
توظف خمسه يردون على التليفون هتوظف واحد
اللي هي همم اعلى اكيد في بعض الوظائف
اكيد في وظائف هتحتاجي الى انسان
يتفاعل معك ويفهمك ويكون ردود اسرع يعني
بالنهايه هذه ماشي
ابسط شيء ما اريد اقول اسمها اللي ترد
علينا على التلفون دائما ابسط شيء دائما
اتلخبطنا وتاخذوها
سمعت الحمد لله ههه